uh nicole maliotakis is a newly elected
republican congresswoman
who will represent staten island and
parts of
southern brooklyn in the house of
representatives nicole
congratulations uh why is this
such a priority for the democrats
well thank you for having me and i have
to tell you that it is disheartening
that this is his focus it's not
providing relief to the millions of
americans that are struggling right now
during this pandemic it's not ensuring
that we help those small
businesses that are hanging on by a
thread due to government restrictions
and mandated shutdowns
it's not how are we going to get this
vaccine to
distributed to our frontline workers at
our most vulnerables across the states
it is actually a policy that would help
the citizens of other countries
not americans and it's very sad that he
wants to dismantle the policies
put in place by president trump that
have been effective
in stemming the tide of illegal
immigration he wants to stop
deportations he wants to also make sure
that we have open borders he does not
want to continue
the construction of the wall he doesn't
want to continue this day in mexico
policy as individuals wait for their
court dates
so this is something that i believe that
he is going to get a fight
from the republicans in congress who are
very much
pleased with the progress we've made
under president trump
and don't want to unravel that you know
you make a
an excellent point there because
president trump was really the first uh
president in a couple of generations to
talk about immigration as public policy
from the point of view
of people who already here in other
words what's it do
for all the people who are already in
the country for american citizens
and doesn't that go double at a time of
pandemic when
uh small businesses have been clobbered
when the people who are
uh are here legally and are legal
american citizens
and look to their government to do
something for them
uh the the prioritizing of this is even
more bizarre it's as if
it's a naked uh attempt to import a new
electorate
well as the daughter of immigrants i can
tell you that i have a deep appreciation
for the aspirations of those who want to
come to this country but
what president uh with the what the uh
what the biden
camp wants to do is basically allow
those who are come to this country
illegally have broken our laws
to go ahead of the line and that is
wrong
and i can tell you as someone who
represents new york in the state
assembly currently
the cost of free college here
a free health care providing free
attorneys of driver's licenses
has all has an impact and it's not the
time to be taking on those additional
burdens
no and you're absolutely right that if
you go to the trouble of doing it
by the book and filling in the paperwork
you don't get these kind of this kind of
special treatment from prominent
democrats
nicole thanks very much for that and
have a terrific
thanksgiving